bonjour à tous j'espère que vous allez
bien je vous souhaite une excellente
année 2022 on se retrouve aujourd'hui
pour la faq 500 mille abonnés cinq cent
mille c'est un chiffre un peu symbolique
un demi million et l'année qui vient de
s'écouler a marqué une forte évolution
de la chaîne puisqu'on est passé d'à peu
près 220 mille abonnés en janvier 2021 à
plus de 500 milles abonnés à l'heure où
je vous parle donc pour cela sachez que
je vous remercie du fond du coeur merci
de suivre les épisodes merci à tous ceux
qui me soutiennent alors certains
d'entre vous le savent mais je pense
qu'ils viennent encore beaucoup qui
l'ignorent à la fin de l'année dernière
j'ai lancé les cours collectifs en visio
donc si ça vous intéresse de suivre un
cours de philosophie mensuel d'une durée
de deux heures sur un thème prédéfini
bien je vous invite à aller sur mon site
internet
www.lepost.fr à vous inscrire à la
lettre d'information pour recevoir
toutes les informations concernant la
tenue des prochains cours est donc dans
ses cours de philosophie on va un peu
plus loin que dans les épisodes
classiques c'est à dire que je pars
d'une thématique je pars d'un concept
que je vais définir que je vais définir
sous plusieurs angles en convoquant
plusieurs auteurs plusieurs courants de
pensée donc pour ceux qui sont
intéressés par ces cours de philosophie
vous avez le lien dans la description et
si vous avez raté les premiers cours et
que vous voulez une session de
rattrapage est bien sur mon site vous
avez la possibilité d'accéder au replay
des anciens courts les cours ont lieu
généralement en milieu de mois un
mercredi soir de 19h à 21h lorsque
l'homme conquiert la nature il utilise
la culture comme un moyen de conquête
donc comme un moyen de combat
contre la nature
mais si on déplace le point de vue
et qu'on entend le mot nature au sens
aristotélicien de potentialités
originelle la culture ç'aurait le
révélateur de notre nature
pour simplifier pour résumer la culture
c'est la nature de l'homme la deuxième
chose c'est que je vous invite à nouveau
à vous abonner à mon compte instagram je
vous le répète à chaque fois mais c'est
important si vous voulez être tenu
informé des actualités notamment si vous
voulez être tenu informé des prochaines
faq et ainsi pouvoir poser vos questions
et comme je sais que parfois des
personnes me font savoir qu'elles
n'étaient pas au courant que je faisais
une faq ou que j'allais parler de tels
sujets dans tel épisode bien le mieux
pour vous soyez au courant c'est tout
simplement de vous abonner à mon compte
instagram et enfin dernière annonce pour
ceux qui souhaitent avoir du contenu
inédit pour ceux qui souhaitent avoir du
contenu supplémentaire et bien il y à un
seul endroit pour ça c'est ma page
patriotes sur patriote vous aurez accès
à tous mes épisodes en avant-première 48
heures avant leur sortie publique et
vous aurez également accès selon la
formule que vous choisissez à des
épisodes inédits les capsules concept
les épisodes retour les faq réservés
tout ça ce sont des épisodes en format
court que je propose sur patriotes pour
remercier toutes les personnes qui
contribuent à soutenir la chaîne donc
tous les liens sont dans la description
et j'en arrête là pour les annonces je
passe maintenant aux réponses à vos
questions alors sachez malgré tout qu'il
y a énormément de questions qui m'ont
été posées et auxquelles j'avais déjà
répondu dans de précédentes faq donc
pour ceux dont je n'aurais pas retenu la
question et bien je vous invite à aller
consulter la playlist faq du précepteur
et peut-être que la question vous m'avez
posé s'y trouvera donc on y va c'est
parti première question imaginiez-vous à
l'ouverture de la chaîne qu'une chaîne
de philosophie pourrait attirer 500
mille abonnés aviez vous tentez des
pronostics pour vous même alors non
comme j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de le dire
je ne pensais pas que ma chaîne pourrait
atteindre un jour les 500 milles abonnés
une chaîne de philosophie en revanche
puisse atteindre les 500 milles abonnés
ça ça ne me paraissait pas irréaliste
parce qu'il existe je pense au moins une
autre chaîne de philosophie qui à plus
de 500 milles abonnés donc dans l'absolu
ça ne me paraissait pas complètement
délirant maintenant que ma chaîne ait pu
atteindre 500 mille abonnés ça m'aurait
paru hautement improbable tout
simplement à cause du format de mes
épisodes c'est à dire un format audio un
format très long très lent par rapport
aux aux codes de ce qui fonctionne
habituellement sur youtube donc de ce
point de vue là j'ai été vraiment le
premier surpris il faut dire que j'ai
aussi bénéficié de l'effet confinement
en 2020 qui a vraiment permis à la
chaîne de décoller mais je pense qu'il
n'y a pas que ce facteur là puisque
depuis la visibilité de la chaîne n'a
pas cessé d'augmenter
donc je pense qu'il y à une véritable
demande il y à une demande de
philosophie il ya une demande de
réflexion posée de réflexion calme et je
pense que je suis par contre l'un des
seuls à répondre à cette demande c'est à
dire à avoir assumé et imposer un format
que très peu de personnes auraient osé
tenter et que étant le seul à proposer
ce format eh bien je me retrouve de fait
à être le seul à répondre à cette
demande pour tout dire lorsque j'ai
lancé ma chaîne mon objectif c'était
d'atteindre 20 mille abonnés en trois
ans donc vingt mille abonnés en trois
ans je crois que en trois ans j'avais
atteint les 300 mille abonnés quelque
chose comme ça peut-être même 400 milles
donc c'est bien la preuve que les
pronostics lorsqu'ils sont fondées
simplement sur des intuitions vague ou
sur des sur des espoirs mêlé de crainte
ne valent pas grand chose c'est pour ça
que je n'ai jamais fait de business plan
pour moi un business plan ça m'a
toujours paru quelque chose d'absurde
parce que je ne conçois pas comment on
peut pronostiquer
comment on peut anticiper la manière
dont les gens vont répondre à ce qu'on
leur propose avant même de leur avoir
proposé jeu suis un pragmatique voire un
pragmatiste je considère que c'est par
l'action c'est par la concrétisation des
choses que l'on peut vraiment savoir
comment le réel répond à nos actes voilà
pour cette réponse question suivante ça
lui donne toujours des cours en
parallèle de youtube est ce toujours ton
activité principale donc je continue à
donner quelques cours particuliers j'ai
gardé quatre élèves parce que ce sont
des élèves que je suis depuis longtemps
maintenant donc je n'avais pas envie de
les abandonner à une année du bac mais à
part ces quatre élèves les seuls cours
que je continue à donner ce sont les
cours collectifs en visio dont je vous
ai parlé au début de cette faq et je
vous invite si vous l'avez oublié avoir
enseigné en allant directement sur mon
site le lien est dans la description
question suivante
salut bravo pour les 500 milles quels
conseils donnerais-tu au présent ou
futur étudiant en philosophie quelle
leçon à tirer de des années à la fac de
philo alors si je devais donner un
conseil aux étudiants en philosophie
c'est de vous poser la question pourquoi
faites-vous des études de philosophie si
vous faites des études de philosophie
parce que vous voulez devenir maître de
conférence c'est à dire professeur à la
fac ou si vous voulez devenir professeur
au lycée posez vous la question est ce
que c'est un métier qui vous correspond
est ce que c'est un métier dans lequel
vous aurez un sentiment d'épanouissement
ou d'accomplissement parce que si ce
n'est pas le cas sachez que vous aurez
très peu de débouchés professionnels et
que c'est pas parce qu'on fait de la
philosophie que l'on doit oublier de
manger donc ça compte la question des
débouchés professionnels et on peut se
débrouiller
lorsqu'on fait de la philosophie pour
trouver un boulot qui n'est pas
directement dans la branche du
professorat mais il faut savoir que ce
n'est pas facile et que il faut avoir
une sacrée dose de courage une sacrée
dose de détermination pour passer outre
ce facteur du débouché professionnel
donc si vous faites de la philosophie
parce que ça correspond à votre intérêt
personnel parce que c'est votre passion
parce que vous considérez qu'il faut
mettre au premier plan cet intérêt cette
passion allez-y mais faites le en
conscience faites le en sachant que si
vous voulez vous orienter vers la
branche du professorat les places sont
très limitées question suivante faut-il
avoir le ventre plein pour philosopher
alors je dirais que ça dépend ça dépend
ce qu'on appelle philosophait c'est à
dire que si la philosophie c'est
l'analyse du monde en vue de sa
compréhension non seulement il n'y a pas
besoin d'avoir le ventre plein mais ça
peut même être une manière de se remplir
le ventre c'est à dire comprendre le
monde comprendre ces lois comprendre
comment il fonctionne c'est ce qui
permet l'adaptation à ce monde or
l'adaptation c'est la condition numéro
un de la survie maintenant si on parle
de philosophes' plus abstraite par
exemple si on philosophe sur l'art si on
philosophe sur le langage sur l'amour
bien là je dirais que ça ne correspond
plus à une nécessité nécessité vitale
donc à ce moment-là remet on peut
considérer que la philosophie devient un
privilège un privilège sociale en tout
cas pour ma part j'assume totalement que
ma pratique de la philosophie c'est à
dire le fait que la philosophie et pu
devenir mon métier c'est un privilège de
ventre plein parce que si je n'avais pas
de quoi me nourrir je ne serais pas en
train de faire des vidéos de philosophie
je serai en train de pousser des
palettes à auch en question suivante
comment t'es-tu entraîné à parler avec
tant d'aisance tuer le même dans la vie
quand tu parles de philo alors je ne me
suis pas entraîné a parlé on va dire que
ça correspond à un mode de
fonctionnement naturel parce que j'aime
le langage parce que j'ai une voix qui
porte donc ça facilite aussi les choses
mais je n'ai pas vraiment cultiver cette
cette disposition quant à savoir si je
suis le même dans la vie quand je parle
de philo je ne peux pas vraiment
répondre à cette question il faudrait
plutôt demandé à mes proches mais ce qui
est certain c'est que lorsqu'on me
branche sur une question de philosophie
j'ai beaucoup de mal à retenir ma
passion et mon engouement je dirais que
lorsque je suis avec mes proches j'ai
peut-être un langage un peu moins châtié
mais en tout cas je pense ne pas avoir
de double personnalité lorsqu'on est sur
youtube ou lorsqu'on est sur une plate
forme de podcasts on n'est jamais
exactement soi même tout simplement
parce que être soi même ça ne veut rien
dire vous n'êtes pas la même personne
vous mêmes selon que vous vous adressez
à quelqu'un de proche ou à quelqu'un que
vous rencontrer pour la première fois
selon que vous parlez à votre patron ou
selon que vous parlez à votre petite
soeur et même lorsque vous êtes sur les
réseaux sociaux lorsque vous faites un
post sur facebook ou sur instagram vous
n'êtes pas vous même vous êtes une
facette de vous même vous êtes un aspect
de vous même être soi même être le même
je ne pense pas que ce soit des
catégories fonctionnel en revanche je
fais en sorte que tout ce qui sort de ma
bouche publiquement ou tout ce que
j'écris publiquement correspondent à la
réalité de ma pensée correspondent au
fond de mon opinion et j'estime que
c'est déjà pas mal question suivante
combien de temps faut-il pour faire un
épisode alors ça dépend comment on
comptait comment on segmente le temps de
travail c'est à dire que pour faire un
épisode il faut déjà que j'ai des
connaissances préalables sur l'auteur
sur le concept sur le courant de pensée
dont je vais parler est ce ton travail
on peut pas vraiment le quantifier parce
que la gelée accumulés au fur et à
mesure du temps au fur et à mesure des
années c'est un peu comme si on
demandait à un médecin combien de temps
il lui faut pour préparer le diagnostic
d'un patient ça marche pas comme ça
faire le diagnostic d'un patient je
dirais que pour un médecin en début de
carrière ça prend plus de temps que pour
un médecin qui a déjà des années des
décennies d'expérience tout simplement
parce que le savoir faire accumulés au
fil des ans fait qu'ensuite on gagne du
temps donc ça veut dire pour prendre un
exemple que si je dois faire un épisode
sur sartre je n'ai pas besoin de relire
l'intégralité de l'oeuvre de sartre mais
par contre je vais prendre le temps de
relire certains textes de l'auteur je
vais prendre le temps aussi de consulter
ce qu'on appelle la littérature
secondaire c'est-à-dire des commentaires
de l'oeuvre et je vais surtout prendre
le temps de poser la réflexion sur le
papier c'est à dire que contrairement à
mes premiers épisodes où je faisais tout
en improvisation
maintenant je prends de plus en plus de
temps pour préparer pour organiser la
réflexion tout simplement parce que je
ne veux pas éteindre mon cros avec le
sentiment d'avoir oublié des choses ou
avec le sentiment d'avoir mal dit
certaines choses surtout que plus on
produit plus on fait des épisodes et
plus on doit être attentif à ne pas trop
se répéter on doit se répéter parce que
c'est incontournable parce que c'est
inévitable et parce qu'aussi la
pédagogie passe par la répétition mais
il faut que la répétition et une
pertinence et je n'ai pas envie de me
répéter parce que je n'ai pas
suffisamment de matière ou parce que je
n'ai pas suffisamment d'idées à
développer donc c'est ça qui nécessite
que je prenne de plus en plus de temps
pour préparer mes épisodes maintenant
pour quand même répondre à la question
de manière concrète on va dire que pour
réaliser un épisode aujourd'hui il me
faut entre 5 à 7 jours à temps plein
réaliser un épisode ce n'est pas
seulement l'enregistrement parce
qu'après l'enregistrement il y a le
montage et même si dans mon cas le
montage et inapparent puisqu'on ne voit
pas de coupure à l'écran ça peut quand
même prendre plusieurs heures question
suivante est ce que tu écoutes des
podcasts si oui et tu agacé par sa
propre voie alors ça c'est une question
intéressante parce que la réponse est
oui ça m'arrive de réécouter certains
anciens épisodes vient justement c'est
dans le prolongement de ce que je disais
il ya un instant pour voir si je ne me
répète pas trop d'épisodes en épisodes
pour voir si je suis toujours satisfait
de ce que j'ai exposé par le passé et ça
m'arrive parfois de pas être satisfait
c'est à dire de me dire que j'aurais pu
le dire mieux que j'aurais pu le dire
autrement mais en même temps je
l'acceptent parce que c'est la preuve
qu'il y a une évolution qui lie à une
progression et je réécoute mes anciens
podcast aussi pour améliorer la qualité
sonore parce que ça aussi c'est un
aspect très important à prendre en
compte l'aspect qu'on sous estime
parfois quand on est à la place du
spectateur c'est à dire l'aspect
technique et pour moi l'exigence
technique l'exigence de qualité audio
fait partie intégrante de mon travail de
vulgarisation sur internet question
suivante comment avez vous fait pour
acquérir un certain vocabulaire très
descriptif alors bon pas très original
j'ai beaucoup lu surtout lorsque j'étais
plus jeune mais je dirais que c'est pas
forcément le faire leur principal parce
que outre la lecture j'ai beaucoup
écouté je suis quelqu'un qui suis assez
sensible aux mots c'est à dire que
j'aime le son des mots j'aime le sens
des mots j'aime apprendre de nouveaux
mots et ça depuis que je suis tout petit
ce qui fait que lorsque je lisais mais
première bande dessinée à 6 ans et que
je tombais sur un mot que je ne
connaissais pas je prenais le temps
d'aller en chercher la définition dans
le dictionnaire et je retenais cette
définition ce qui fait que mon
vocabulaire c'est naturellement étendu
durant toute mon enfance et durant mon
adolescence quant au fait que mon
vocabulaire est très descriptif c'est
vrai et je dirais que c'est lié à mon
côté pragmatique c'est à dire des mais
les choses concrètes d'aimer les choses
précises de ne pas aimer les mots creux
il y a rien qui m'insupporte plus qu'un
discours vide qu'un discours creux sur
le plan du concept et c'est aussi pour
ça que le slogan de ma chaîne s'est
donné matière à penser parce que la
matière c'est concret et je considère
qu'une pensée qui n'est pas concrète ou
en tout cas qui n'est pas concrètement
exposé à bien des risques d'être une
pensée creuse il ya beaucoup de
personnes qui utilisent leur vocabulaire
qui utilise des mots savants pour
masquer la vacuité de leur discours
parce qu'ils savent que utiliser des
mots savants ça va impressionner une
partie du public et donc ça va donner
l'impression que ce qu'on dit est
intelligente même si on n'a pas compris
moi je fonctionne totalement à l'opposé
c'est à dire que je considère qu'un
discours est intelligent quand la
personne qui le porte a réussi à me le
faire comprendre là où je n'aurais pas
pensé pouvoir le comprendre de moi même
et si mon vocabulaire est très
descriptif c'est peut-être aussi pour
une autre raison qui est que j'ai une
pensée très visuel j'ai l'habitude de
visualiser les idées de visualiser les
cheminements pensée et ça c'est quelque
chose qui est totalement indépendant de
ma volonté c'est un mode de
fonctionnement que je n'ai pas choisi
question suivante
le charles est ce que tu arrives à
reposer ton esprit avec toutes ces
réflexions car tu te donnes à toi même
j'imagine matière à penser oui c'est
vrai que ça peut m'arriver parfois de me
laisser emporter dans le tourbillon de
ma propre pensée mais j'ai appris avec
le temps à m'en extraire c'est à dire à
ne pas être l'esclave de la pensée comme
dirait écartelée parce que bien souvent
ce n'est pas en insistant dans la
réflexion qu'on trouve des réponses bien
souvent c'est par rapport à l'angle sous
lequel on pose la réflexion que l'on
peut ou pas atteindre les réponses
question suivante
c'est le charles quelle est la vidéo
dont tu es le plus fier actuellement et
pourquoi alors ça risque d'en étonner
certains mais la vidéo dont je suis le
plus fier actuellement c'est mon
portrait philo sur rocchi alors ya
évidemment des raisons affectives
ah ça c'est à dire que mes portraits
philo porte sur des personnages qui bien
souvent ont baigné mon enfance ma
jeunesse où une partie de ma vie ou pour
ceux qui l'auraient pas encore vu je
vous invite fortement à aller voir cet
épisode sur rocchi et je suis certain
que vous allez tomber amoureux de ce
personnage question suivante à prendre
se fait-il le mieux en s'isolant ou en
discutant avec les gens quittent a
exposé son ignorance je dirais que c'est
les deux on apprend en échangeant et on
apprend en s'isolant discuter avec les
autres c'est ce qui permet de mettre ces
idées à l'épreuve c'est à dire de les
confronter et de voir quelles contre
arguments on peut y opposer s'isoler
c'est ce qui permet de se questionner
sur soi de questionner ses expériences
de faire le bilan de ces expériences
mais si on reste tout le temps tout seul
avec sa propre pensée et bien on crée
une sorte d'auto aliénation ont créé un
écosystème mentale dont on peut plus
sortir nokia que c'est vraiment ce
double mouvement cette alternance entre
introspection et expressions qui permet
le mieux d'apprendre c'est à dire
d'enrichir sa pensée question suivante
tu accorde beaucoup d'importance à
l'étymologie des mots as-tu appris le
grec et le latin qu'est-ce que tu en a
retiré alors j'ai fait du latin pendant
six ans je n'ai pas fait de grecs et je
le regrette presque je le regrette
presse parce que je me dis que ça
m'aurait fait gagner du temps dans
l'analyse de certains concepts puisque
pour le cas du français l'étymologie et
la plupart du temps latine mais aussi
parfois grecque oui ça m'a beaucoup
apporté d'apprendre le latin même si à
l'époque je ne m'en rendais pas
forcément compte puisque quand on est
adolescent à prendre les déclinaisons à
prendre les désinence ce n'est pas
extrêmement palpitant mais quand j'ai
commencé les études de philosophie et
que j'ai vu à quel point l'étymologie
l'origine des maux étaient essentiels à
la compréhension de certains concepts
c'est là je me suis rendu compte que
j'en avais retirer beaucoup et par
ailleurs et ça c'est peut-être mon côté
un peu plus artiste entre guillemets
je suis extrêmement sensible et
réceptifs aux liens invisibles entre les
mots c'est à dire aux liens étymologique
qui permettent tout à coup d'éclairer un
mot sous un jour nouveau jeu prendre un
exemple tout bête qui me traverse
l'esprit c'est le mot humain lorsque je
me suis rendu compte que humains
humilité et humus avait la même
étymologie mais je me suis dit que là je
venais de découvrir quelque chose
pourquoi et bien parce que l'humus c'est
la terre l'humain celles habitant de la
terre et l'humilité c'est la capacité à
ne pas se donner une valeur trop haute
autrement dit à garder les pieds sur
terre et bien savoir ça je trouve
personnellement que c'est extrêmement
stimulant pour la pensée et que si tout
à coup on me privait de cet outil qu'est
l'étymologie et l'analyse de la racine
des mots je serai très malheureux
question suivante est il nécessaire
d'établir sa propre terminologie pour
être philosophe alors je dirais que
établir sa propre terminologie c'est à
dire construire son propre vocabulaire
philosophique bien souvent ça a un
intérêt qui est de rendre sa pensée
immédiatement identifiable ce que je
veux dire par là c'est qu'il ya des
auteurs qui sont connus pour avoir forgé
des concepts et peut-être qu'on ne les
aurais pas connu qu'on ne les aurais pas
reconnus s'ils n'avaient pas forger leur
propre terminologie s'il n'avait pas
créé leur propre concept je prendre un
exemple qui est heidegger heidegger
alors ils écrivent en allemand et je ne
sais pas si ce concept existe dans
l'allemand courant mais il a forgé le
concept de dasein pour décrire l'être
humain c'est-à-dire pour décrire
l'existant alors dasein en français ça
se traduirait littéralement par être là
mais on a renoncé à traduire ce concept
en français parce que ça n'allait pas ce
n'était pas vraiment pertinent et bien
lorsque vous parlez de heidegger à des
philosophes très rapidement il va leur
revenir à l'esprit le concept de design
et il est fort possible que si heidegger
n'avait pas forger un tel concept il ya
peut-être qu'on n'aurait pas autant
retenu sa pensée peut-être que ça
pensait n'aurait pas marqué les esprits
comme elle a marqué les esprits alors
évidemment il ne suffit pas de créer des
concepts pour que tout à coup notre
pensée de vienne génial ou pour que tout
à coup on accède à la reconnaissance
soit la notoriété mais l'idée c'est que
créer des concepts créer sa propre
terminologie ça peut avoir un intérêt
dans la diffusion de sa pensée et dans
le marquage des esprits question
suivante ton expérience de youtube
heures at elle fait évoluer sa vision
des choses voir tes convictions alors
question intéressante la réponse est oui
mon expérience de youtube heures mon
expérience de podcasteurs m'a fait
reconsidérer certaines choses que je
pensais sur les youtube heures lorsque
j'étais de l'autre côté de l'écran c'est
à dire lorsque je n'étais qu'un simple
spectateur en fait quand on est
spectateur on développe une approche
sans même s'en rendre compte qui hélas
proche du consommateur c'est à dire
qu'on se met à avoir des attentes on se
met à avoir même des exigences des
exigences par exemple sur la fréquence
de publication des épisodes on estime
que le créateur de contenu à un devoir
envers nous qui est de nous livrer notre
épisode en temps et en heure où on
considère que si un des épisodes nous
plaît moins on va pas se dire qu'il nous
plaît moins on va dire qu'il est moins
réussie où on va dire que le uber n'a
pas fourni le travail habituel et donc
on va se mettre dans la position du juge
dans la position du professeur de
l'inspecteur des travaux finis et ça
c'est une tendance qu'on développe tous
à partir du moment où on met à notre
disposition un contenu qui plus est un
contenu gratuit et ce comportement de
consommateur dont je répète qu'il est
bien souvent inconscients et
involontaire il vient aussi du fait
qu'on ne se rend pas du tout compte de
la quantité de travail qui peut y avoir
derrière un épisode et qui donne une
impression de facilité qui donne
l'impression que le youtuber n'a fait
qu'allumer sa caméra parler et
l'éteindre mais je peux vous dire que ça
marche pas du tout comme ça et que au
moment même où je suis en train
d'enregistrer cette faq vous n'imaginez
pas toute l'installation qu'il ya autour
de moi pour que je puisse enregistrer
dans des bonnes conditions vous
n'imaginez pas la durée que peut prendre
l'enregistrement de cette faq puisque je
pense qu'elle va durer environ 45
minutes à une heure mais en termes
d'enregistrement on est sur du 3 à 4
heures et donc cette impression de
facilité qui est celle de toute personne
à qui on livre un produit fini elle crée
en nous une tendance à l'exigence une
tendance à la réclamation est donc ce
tempérament du consommateur je l'avais
lorsque j'étais spectateur et je ne
l'est plus maintenant que je suis
producteur voilà pour cette réponse
question suivante précepteur pourrais-tu
réalisé une vidéo sur la mythologie
égyptienne antique
alors toi je crois que tu te moques de
moi cyrus north youtuber philo lui aussi
nous dit que le pass et la liberté au
point de vue mon point de vue c'est que
plus c'est gros plus ça passe
moi c'est quand j'entends ce genre de
choses que je comprends les personnes
qui voient la philosophie comme l'art du
boniment et l'art de la masturbation
intellectuelle parce qu'on peut défendre
théoriquement tout position à partir du
moment où on a des arguments cohérent et
logique je comprends qu'on puisse
défendre des mesures de restriction de
liberté au nom de la sécurité mais la
démarche qui consiste
à élaborer un raisonnement ultra
sophistiqué dans lequel on va passer par
la porte de service pour revenir par la
fenêtre et nous expliquer qu'en fait le
blanc et noir avec le noir et blanc ça
c'est du foutage de gueule le problème
n'est pas d'avoir telle ou telle
position le problème est de se servir de
la philosophie pour défendre des
positions dont on pense qu'elles sont
intelligentes parce qu'elle contredise
l'évidence le pas ce n'est pas la
liberté le pass est une restriction de
liberté le pass est une injonction à
l'obéissance et on peut considérer que
c'est bien mais il ne faut pas nous
faire croire que c'est ça la liberté
question suivante
selon vous la valeur d'un homme se
définit par le courage y at il d'autres
youtuber dont le travail de
vulgarisation de la philosophie te
semble pertinent alors sans parler de la
philosophie il y a des youtuber qui font
la vulgarisation et pour qui j'éprouve
un immense respect et leur travail de
vulgarisation généralement se fait dans
des domaines que je ne maîtrise pas ou
en tout cas qui ne sont pas mes domaines
de compétence au départ et d'ailleurs je
pense que je suis bien mieux placé pour
juger le travail de vulgarisateur dans
d'autres domaines que la philosophie
puisque précisément la vulgarisation
s'adresse à des novices donc là
j'aimerais parler de david louapre de la
chaîne science étonnante qui fait un
travail absolument remarquable
je pense et je pèse mes mots que c'est
le meilleur vulgarisateur que je puisse
connaître toutes catégories confondues
c'est quelqu'un qui va vous parler avec
une clarté avec une humidité et en même
temps avec une rigueur et une précision
qui prend à part fort son admiration
vous avez certainement déjà vu les
expériences amusantes qu'on peut faire
avec un mélange d'eau et de maïzena si
on a les bonnes proportions on obtient
une substance bizarre qui coule entre
les doigts comme un liquide mais si on
la manipule vigoureusement elle se
travaille comme de la pâte à modeler et
semble être plutôt solide si on tape
dessus violemment aucune éclaboussures
c'est comme si on avait tapé sur un
morceau de caoutchouc alors est ce que
pour cette matière étrange on parle de
dualité solide liquide ben non on a fini
par admettre qu'il s'agit d'une dans ce
plus complexe qu'un simple liquide ou un
simple solide et qui suivant
l'expérience qu'on fait avec se comporte
comme là où comme l'autre la dualité on
corpuscules en mécanique quantique on
pourra dire que c'est pareil à les objet
quantique sont des trucs plus compliqué
que de simples particuliers ou de
simples aux ondes et le comportement
qu'ils auront dépendra de l'expérience
qu'on réalise donc si vous avez un
intérêt pour la science mais que vous
faites partie comme moi des personnes
qui n'ont pas le bagage en termes de
connaissances foncé aller sur la chaîne
science étonnante et je peux vous dire
que vous allez apprendre énormément de
choses un autre vulgarisateur alors
c'est pas vraiment un vulgarisateur en
fait ce serait plutôt un documentariste
mais dont j'aime le travail parce que je
lui trouve un point commun avec le mien
qui est d'être un travail à la fois
artisanale mais rigoureux c'est à dire
on sent qu'il y a une envie de bien
faire c'est paul de la chaîne de paul
qui propose des mini documentaires
sur des personnages ou sur des sujets de
la pop culture et je trouve qu'il a
cette capacité à nous faire nous
intéresser à des choses qui ne nous
aurait pas forcément intéressés de prime
abord collaborer avec miramax s'est
avéré pour beaucoup une expérience
difficile voire traumatisante
en plus d'être un négociateur
intransigeant qui ne cède rien sans rien
harvey a des prétentions artistiques et
se sert de sa position pour un droit de
regard sur la production finale
adepte des projections tests souvent
considérée comme une infamie dans le
cinéma indépendant il insiste pour
remonter un film voir tourner des scènes
supplémentaires réécrire la fin si les
résultats ne sont pas bons d'où son
surnom avait six heures m le réalisateur
refuse d'obéir pas de souci harvey
menace une sortie confidentielle ou
direct vidéo qui lui évite de perdre de
l'argent tout en humiliant le cinéaste
certains résistent comme tarantino à qui
il voulait faire enlever la scène de
torture de reservoir dogs mais la
plupart finissent par se coucher donc
voilà les deux vulgarisateur que je
pourrais vous conseillez même si ce
n'était pas exactement la question david
louapre de la chaîne science étonnante
et paul de la chaîne de paul question
suivante pas de questions mais je te
remercie d'avoir mis au clair ce que je
trouvais très difficile merci à toi mike
solide mike dont je vous invite à aller
voir les vidéos sur youtube vidéos de
motivation de musculation et d'humour
comment faites-vous pour éveiller
l'intérêt d'une personne un sujet que
vous souhaitez développer utilisez vous
une méthode particulière alors ça dépend
du contexte
si je réalise un épisode et que mon but
c'est d'éveiller l'intérêt et
l'attention de mon auditeurs à ce moment
là je vais utiliser des méthodes
appelons ça des méthodes mais ce sont
des méthodes de professeurs c'est à dire
des méthodes de pédagogue est la
meilleure méthode pour un pédagogue et
bien c'est de cerner l'intérêt de celui
qui nous écoutent et de partir de ce qui
l'intéresse c'est à dire que un
vulgarisateur youtuber où un professeur
qui arrivent et qui balance ce qu'il a
envie de balancer sans tenir compte de
ce qui intéresse son public là pour moi
c'est quelqu'un qui ne respecte pas son
public et donc s'il ne respecte pas son
public il ne peut pas attendre de son
public de l'écouté de la tension c'est
ce que disait la fontaine dans le
pouvoir des fables il explique que nous
avons tous une âme d'enfant un enfant il
suit naturellement sa curiosité et
l'adulte fonctionne exactement comme
l'enfant l'adulte a besoin que son
intérêt soit stimulée que sa curiosité
soient titillés pour pouvoir offrir son
attention nokia une différence entre le
divertissement et la captation de
l'intérêt et la captation l'intérêt
c'est quelque chose qui peut être
extrêmement pertinent dans une démarche
pédagogique parce que c'est ça qui fait
qu'on ne va plus parler tout seul mais
qu'on va s'adresser à quelqu'un
maintenant quand je parle avec les gens
dans la vie quotidienne
je ne met pas en place de méthodes
rhétorique de captation de la tension
je parle avec les gens j'essaye de
trouver des sujets d'intérêts communs
sur lesquels on va discuter mais je ne
pratique pas mon métier de pédagogue
avec les personnes que je rencontre
question suivante
arrives tu à mettre en application ce
que tu as appris où la nature reprend le
dessus dans la vraie vie alors ça c'est
une question un peu difficile parce que
bien souvent on a l'impression que le
fait de faire de la philosophie nous
immuniserait contre certaines
difficultés de la vie auxquels sont
confrontés le commun des mortels c'est
une illusion bien évidemment que on peut
être un grand philosophe où on peut être
un professeur de philosophie ont peu
évolué dans la sphère de la sagesse et
des idées et pour autant ne pas les
mettre en application dans sa propre vie
ou en tout cas ne pas considérer qu'on a
la réponse à tous les problèmes en
revanche le fait est que si on associe à
sa pratique de la philosophie un
véritable travail sur soi c'est à dire
qu'on n'ait pas simplement dans
l'acquisition et la restitution de
connaissances mais bel et bien dans une
démarche d'évolution personnelle il ya
en ce moment là la philosophie va nous
permettre de mieux vivre comme dit andré
comte sponville c'est à dire de mieux
comprendre la manière dont le réel
répond à nos agissements mais ça c'est
un travail et une évolution qui se fait
sur du long terme et qu'on ne peut pas
vraiment dissocier qu'on ne peut pas
vraiment séparer de ce qu'on appelle
couramment la maturité et qui est liée à
l'expérience de la vie question suivante
quel est d'après toi ta plus grande
faiblesse ce que tu voudrais comblé
alors l'une de mes plus grandes
faiblesses c'est mon impatience
impatience parce que par exemple
actuellement je suis en train
d'enregistrer cette faq comme je voulais
dit je sais que l'enregistrement va
durer longtemps plusieurs heures or il
se trouve que j'aimerais bien ne pas
faire que ça de ma journée parce que ben
j'ai du travail j'ai d'autres choses à
faire et donc je pense au fait pendant
que je suis en train d'enregistrer que
je ne peux pas me permettre de passer
toute ma journée a enregistré cette faq
ce qui est d'ailleurs en contradiction
avec certains auteurs dont j'ai pu
parler sur ma chaîne parmi lesquels
écart tollé le pouvoir du moment présent
il ya le moment présent c'est quelque
chose que j'ai déjà réussi à
expérimenter mais ce n'est pas non plus
un état permanent pour moi donc autant
je peux avoir un rapport au temps
extrêmement décontractée par exemple
quand je suis à table quand je suis au
restaurant je déteste qu'on me presse je
déteste qu'on me dise l'heure qu'il est
autant quand je suis en train
d'effectuer une tâche et que je sais que
j'ai d'autres tâches à effectuer mais à
ce moment là je vais me soucier du temps
qui passe ça va nourrir en moi une forme
d'impatience qui constitue à mes yeux
une faiblesse question suivante
al pacino et de niro
de niro comment faire pour te concentrer
plutôt sur l'aspect positif des choses
au lieu des inconvénients je dirais que
pour se concentrer sur l'aspect positif
des choses il faut en prendre l'habitude
parce que ce n'est pas quelque chose
qu'on peut décréter vous savez quand on
dit par exemple à quelqu'un
ça te fait du mal n'y pense plus ça te
fait du mal ça va passer tu devrais
essayer de te connecter aux éléments tu
devrais essayer de te connecter aux
énergies positives ça ne marche pas ça
ne marche pas parce que ça ne peut
marcher que sur des personnes qui ont
déjà réussi à focaliser sur le positif
et quand je dis ça ne marche pas je dis
ça sans savoir s'il y a quelque chose
qui marche tout ce que je sais c'est que
dans mon cas un moment donné j'ai essayé
de me concentrer sur le positif et j'ai
fini par me rendre compte au bout d'un
certain nombre de mois que j'avais
développé le réflexe naturel de me
concentrer sur les choses positives
question suivante
quelle est la façon la plus sûre
d'atteindre nos buts
je dirais
organisation
persévérance
et folie
est-ce qu'il faut travailler pour vivre
ou vivre pour travailler
la fameuse question le fameux chiasme
philosophique bien il faut d'abord
travailler pour vivre parce qu'il faut
bien remplir le ventre il faut bien
nourrir le corps la dimension matérielle
qui nous rattache à la vie mais une fois
je m'étais fait la réflexion que si la
nature avait voulu nous pousser au
travail elle ne s'y serait pas pris
autrement à savoir en nous faisant avoir
des enfants un jour je discutais avec
mon beau-frère donc le mari de ma soeur
il venait d'avoir un enfant et donc il
m'expliquait que depuis qu'il avait un
enfant il se levait beaucoup plus
facilement le matin pour aller
travailler parce que désormais son
travail avait un sens il avait une
finalité concrètes et ultime est donc
pour lui avoir un enfant était devenu
une source de motivation dans son
travail donc ça c'est une idée assez
classique n'était pas vraiment une
pensée nouvelle est par contre ça fait
naître une autre idée dans mon esprit
qui est que peut-être ne travaillons pas
pour nourrir ses enfants peut-être at-on
des enfants pour travailler peut-être y
at-il un esprit de la nature un esprit
l'univers qui s'est rendu compte que
pour nous mettre au travail il fallait
nous donner une source de motivation et
que cette source de motivation on la
trouve dans les enfants c'est à dire
dans la perpétuation de soi à travers le
temps et donc si on considère comme
hegel que le travail c'est la
manifestation de la conscience humaine à
travers l'histoire eh bien peut-être que
le travail n'est pas la condition de la
reproduction mais peut-être que c'est la
reproduction qui est la condition du
travail peut-être que c'est l'amour de
nos enfants qui est là pour nous faire
travailler c'est-à-dire pour faire en
sorte que la conscience universelle
advienne parce que c'est ça pour eagle
le sens du travail s'est déposé notre
empreinte dans le monde façonné la
nature à notre image pour qu'advienne la
conscience voilà pour cette réponse
question suivante quelle combat
entretenez-vous contre votre propre
esprit alors je dirais que j'essaye dans
la mesure du possible de ne pas me
conformer à des catégories préétablies
c'est à dire de ne pas me conformer à ce
qu'on appelle communément le
prêt-à-penser quand on vit dans une
société on développe naturellement des
réflexes intellectuelle des réflexes de
penser qu'ils sont liés à l'air du temps
idéologique on est tous plus ou moins
influencée par l'air du temps
idéologique ce qui fait que certaines
questions qui sont posées par exemple
dans les grands débats de société ou
dans les débats politiques bien on finit
par ne les appréhender que sous le
prisme de la doxa que sous le prisme de
l'idéologie dominante et ça pour moi
c'est le poison de la philosophie et
c'est le poison de la pensée libre en
général c'est à dire qu'on va considérer
que face à une question si on donne
telle ou telle réponse eh bien ça veut
dire qu'on appartient à tel ou tel camp
à telle ou telle mouvance et c'est
vraiment de ça que j'essaye le plus de
m'éloigner c'est à dire que sur
certaines questions concrètement je vais
avoir une position qui sera jugée
conservatrice et puis sur d'autres
questions je vais avoir une position qui
sera jugée progressiste mais pour moi le
piège c'est justement de raisonner en
ces termes c'est à dire de considérer
que avoir une position conservatrice sur
un sujet fait de nous un conservateur ou
qu'à voir sur un sujet une positions
progressistes fait de nous un
progressiste et je ne parle même pas des
catégories de gauche de droite qui sont
pour moi totalement obsolète et qui
n'ont aucune autre fonction que de
maintenir un clivage au sein de la
population mais dans tous les cas le
fait de s'affilier un groupe de penser
le fait des tic t sa pensée c'est déjà
remet une défaite de la pensée et c'est
ce qui fait que je peux parler sans
aucune animosité avec quelqu'un qui sera
aux antipodes de mes opinions dès lors
que cette personne ait dans une démarche
de dialogue dans une démarche de
compréhension réciproque et donc je ne
préjuge pas de la pensée des gens
simplement sur l'une de leurs positions
ça c'est vraiment le le combat
intellectuel que j'essaye de mener ty y
un de pouvoir tout entendre et de tenter
de tout comprendre alors évidemment
quand on entend pour la énième fois le
même discours les mêmes éléments de
langage sur un sujet bon ben on a
tendance c'est bien normal à catégoriser
la personne avec qui on parle mais je
laisse toujours une place à la
possibilité d'être surpris et je laisse
également toujours une place à la
possibilité de changer d'avis ou en tout
cas de réviser mes positions à partir du
moment où j'entends des arguments qui me
semblent convaincants et puis il ya une
autre chose qui est que avec le temps on
n'a pas la même appréhension des choses
on ne regarde pas les choses sous le
même angle et donc on n'aura pas la même
opinion sur un sujet selon qu'on aura 20
ans 30 ans ou 40 ans que quelqu'un de 20
ans me disent que pour lui avoir des
enfants c'est quelque chose qui va le
priver de liberté je peux l'entendre
mais j'entendrai tout autant que
quelqu'un de 30 ans ou de 40 ans me
disent qu'avoir des enfants c'est le
sens ultime de la vie pourquoi parce que
les priorités ne sont pas les mêmes
parce que le mode de vie n'est pas le
même et compense en grande partie à
partir de son mode de vie à partir de
son contexte matérielles d'existence et
c'est pas évident de se dire qu'une
opinion qu'on a eu pendant cinq dix ou
quinze ans bien moment donné on ne se
trouve plus en accord avec elle et ça ne
veut pas dire qu'on rnis compenser ça
veut dire qu'on fait évoluer ce qu'on
pensait ça veut dire qu'on fait vivre la
pensée et la pensée pour moi c'est
quelque chose de vivant question
suivante quelle serait la société idéale
de nos jours selon 3 alors moi je
m'interdis
d'exposer ma conception de la société
idéale pourquoi parce que déjà je trouve
que ça n'a pas d'intérêt une société
idéale c'est une société dont on sait
qu'elle n'a deviendra jamais donc je ne
vois pas l'intérêt de perdre du temps
avec ça la deuxième chose c'est que
lorsqu'on parle de société idéale
lorsqu'on parle d'utopie on a toujours
les mêmes choses qui reviennent c'est
toujours les mêmes principes et les
mêmes valeurs qui reviennent principes
de justice le principe de liberté où le
principe d'égalité parce que même les
personnes qui vont défendre
prioritairement
liberté ne vont pas dire qu'elles sont
pour l'injustice où qu'elle sont pour la
loi de la jungle et inversement les
personnes qui prônent l'égalité ne vont
pas à dire qu'elles sont pour la
dictature donc bien sûr il peut y avoir
des différences sur les principes
fondamentaux mais globalement si on
parle de société idéale la majorité des
gens sont d'accord entre eux et puis il
ya une dernière chose qui est que pour
moi la société idéale on doit par la
rêver on ne doit pas l'espérer on doit
la construire autour de soi on doit la
construire à son échelle et c'est pour
ça que je ne m'intéresse absolument plus
à la politique parce que la politique
c'est le projet illusoire d'étendre à
une nation un projet d'existence qu'on
ne daigne pas accomplir autour de soi
moi je trouve ça très bien que les gens
échangent des idées échange des
principes échange d conception idéale
mais je trouverais plus pertinents et
donc plus convaincant si ces personnes
appliquez ces changements dans leur vie
quotidienne quand on prône la
convivialité les changes
le partage est que dans sa vie
quotidienne on vit seule on n'a pas
d'amis on est asocial je suis désolé
mais pour moi il ya une contradiction
insurmontable
donc je préfère pour ma part avoir un
peu moins de grands principes mais un
peu plus de cohérence entre mes opinions
et ma pratique quotidienne donc on peut
trouver ça un peu désenchanté on peut
trouver ça décevant de la part de
quelqu'un qui parle de philosophie de
dire que cette idée de société idéale
n'a pas de sens il faut bien comprendre
que la philosophie ce n'est pas
simplement l'art de l'abstraction c'est
aussi l'art de l'articulation entre
l'abstraction et le réel c'est un petit
peu mon refrain c'est un petit peu ma
marotte et je pense qu'il faut partir du
réel partir du concret et que
l'abstraction ne doit pas être ce qui
s'oppose à la réalité mais ce qui doit
prolonger la réalité question suivante
pourquoi l'humain est il autant
intéressé alors si par l'intéressé tu
veux dire qui agi par intérêt
je dirais que l'humain est intéressé par
ce que l'humain est un animal
nous sommes des animaux nous sommes des
animaux qui avons un intérêt vital qui
est l'intérêt liée à la survie et je
suis partisan de l'idée que nos pensées
sont la théorisation nos intérêts pas
forcément de nos intérêts individuels ça
peut être également de nos intérêts en
tant que groupe même de nos intérêts en
tant qu'humain donc dire que nous
agissons par intérêt c'est pas forcément
négatif en soi moi je pense qu'il ya un
intérêt humain universel je pense qu'il
y à un bien commun je pense que la santé
est un intérêt universel que la
connaissance l'éducation sont des
intérêts universel et en raisonnant
comme ça j'ai pas l'impression que
l'intérêt soit quelque chose de
dégradant donc agir par intérêt ne veut
pas dire forcément agir de manière
égoïste et puis faut pas oublier que ce
n'est pas toujours l'autre qui est
intéressé et nous qui serions vertueux
parce que j'ai toujours tendance à
trouver simple facile la posture
accusatrice
la posture justicière qui consiste à
pointer ce qui ne va pas autour de nous
pour finalement pouvoir mieux
s'abstraire de ce qui ne va pas en nous
dire ce qui ne va pas chez l'autre
pointer les défauts entretenir un
discours résolument pessimiste sur la
nature humaine
ça ne me semble pas être de nature à
améliorer la condition humaine donc à
chaque fois qu'on est dans cette
démarche accusatrice est pessimiste est
finalement au fait concrètement le
contraire de ce qu'on prône dans la
théorie donc plutôt que de dire que
l'humain est intéressé j'aurais tendance
à dire que l'humain est capable du
meilleur comme du pire et que à mon avis
on ne combat pas le pire en focalisant
toute notre attention sur lui
question suivante un sujet à propos
duquel vous auriez changer d'avis bien
ça justement ça c'est quelque chose à
propos de quoi j'ai changé d'avis c'est
à dire qu'il ya encore dix ans peut-être
je considérais que pour améliorer les
choses il fallait dénoncer dénoncer ce
qui n'allait pas dénoncer les injustices
ou en tout cas ce qui m'apparaissait à
moi comme relevant l'injustice et
surtout je pense que ça traduit une
vérité fondamentale sur nous-mêmes qui
est que quand on va mal on veut que le
monde aille mal on veut que le monde
aille mal c'est à dire on veut pouvoir
trouver des choses qui ne vont pas pour
pouvoir les dénoncer pour pouvoir les
combattre et ainsi pour pouvoir se
présenter au monde et à soi même comme
quelqu'un qui oeuvre pour le bien et ça
c'est un discours que je n'ai plus envie
d'entendre c'est un discours que je n'ai
plus envie de porter parce que ça me
semble être non seulement extrêmement
démobilisateur le fait de focaliser sur
tout ce qui ne va pas et de ce point de
vue là pour moi celui qui se retire de
la société pour vivre en conformité avec
ses principes et ses valeurs
bien c'est lui qui a tout compris celui
qui a tout compris c'est celui qui met
ses actes en cohérence avec ses idées en
cohérence avec son discours et qui ne
cherchent pas à convaincre l'autre que
si l'autre ne pense pas de la même façon
c'est un imbécile ou que c'est un [ __ ]
ou que c'est un méchant parce que ça
c'est de l'infantilisation et
l'infantilisation est l'antichambre de
la déresponsabilisation
question suivante
quel est ton oeuvre d'art préféré alors
tout dépend ce qu'on appelle oeuvres
d'art puisqu'on pourrait inclure les
monuments architecturaux puisque l'
architecture est un art mais si on se
limite par exemple aux arts picturaux
mon oeuvre préférée c'est un tableau de
léonard de vinci qui n'est pas très
connu qui s'appelle la sq apic l'iata et
je ne saurais pas dire pourquoi cette
peinture est mon oeuvre d'art préféré
parce que déjà on n'est même pas certain
qu'elle soit l'oeuvre de léonard de
vinci il se pourrait que ce soit
l'oeuvre d'un de ses élèves mais c'est
une oeuvre qui quand j'observe me plonge
dans un état assez indescriptible et
donc ce tableau que je vous met à
l'écran c'est mon oeuvre d'art préféré
et sur le plan musical
mon oeuvre préférée c'est la septième
symphonie de beethoven et notamment le
deuxième mouvement qui est je pense le
la seule oeuvre musicale qui arrive à
m'arracher une larme question suivante
comment se remettre d'une trahison
en l'oublions et enfin dernière question
et toi as-tu une questions à nous poser
ce que je pourrais vous poser comme
question ce serait de vous demander
qu'est ce que la philosophie
a changé dans votre vie
qu'est ce qu'elle vous a apporté que ce
soit
intellectuellement et spirituellement
mais aussi concrètement est ce qu'elle
vous a apporté de la joie est ce qu'elle
vous a apporté des opportunités est ce
qu'elle vous a apporté une évolution
dans votre vie professionnelle ou dans
vos relations avec les autres j'aimerais
savoir ce que la philosophie si vous a
apporté par ce que je sais ce que la
philosophie m'a apporté personnellement
mais je ne sais pas ce qu'elle vous a
apporté à vous et pour reprendre ce que
j'ai dit dans une de mes précédentes
réponses
à prendre c'est aussi sortir de soi et
demander aux autres ce qu'ils en pensent
parce que les autres sont les pièces
manquantes de notre puzzle donc il ya
des choses dont je suis conscient il y a
des choses dont je ne suis pas
conscients et cette petite brique de
conscience c'est vous qui pouvait me
l'apporté donc je vous laisse vous
exprimer dans les commentaires dites-moi
ce que la philosophie vous a apporté et
peut-être qu'en répondant à cette
question et qu'en lisant les réponses
des autres à cette même question
vous allez faire comme moi vous allez
trouver des pièces manquantes de votre
puzzle dans une période aussi
incertaine que celle que nous vivons
peut-être que c'est la meilleure chose
qu'on puisse faire
c'est changer des briques de conscience
pour compte non pas la société idéale
et le monde dans lequel nous voulons
vivre
bonne année
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]